hey man that right there ain't supposed
to be like that my elbows that shouldn't
be double jointed
yeah that shouldn't been like
looked like it hurt didn't it
what like ultimately brought you
to phoenix like what made you
my coach really yeah
just because he
so i was finishing my career i had like
two years year and a half left in my
career
and he goes i'm gonna take the head
coaching job at asu would you come i was
like yeah sure why not
for me
seeing the sunshine every day
is wonders just make you feel good yeah
like you can wake up and feel absolutely
terrible and just go outside and stand
in the sun and get some nice vitamin d
and you feel like a different person so
here we are five years later the rest is
history
[Music]
felt what's happening
all right yeah okay complain and
appreciate you being here
first and foremost i thought we'd do it
here because we both love golf we didn't
play golf a few times i won't talk about
how bad i didn't meet him
but um
you know to start it off just
a little bit about yourself and you know
where you're from baltimore uh born and
raised in baltimore maryland the
youngest of three
the baby boy the only boy i played
baseball lacrosse soccer and swam until
i was like 11 years old and then
decided to focus on swimming only
because my coach told me i could make
the olympic team and
then everything kind of took off but did
somebody swim like around you like i
know your mom and she's we so my sisters
both swim
whitney my middle sister was
internationally was number three in the
world number one in the nation at 15.
there were 13. swimming swimming
and then
i saw her just doing all these cool
things and i was like i want to do that
like i want to go to rome and swim there
and go to world championships and have a
chance to go to the olympics so at the
age of 11
my coach sat down with myself and my
parents and was like you have an
opportunity to do something really
special in four years
if i was like okay what
no other sports you're dropping the
other sports so
i was focused on swimming and that was
it so as an 11 year old kid
i heard the word olympics
and i was all in that was it
that young at 11. yeah just having the
opportunity to to represent your country
win an olympic gold medal like for me i
wanted to break world record and the
only route to be able to have that
chance was swimming at the highest level
what was it like then though like what
was the
preparation like at 11 for like swimming
was you like swimming before school
swimming after school um i mean back
then i was probably only swimming a
handful times a week maybe five days a
week but you was always that nice uh
probably not
um i mean i think i got better and
better pretty quick so when you was in
high school
right like i was never
caught near a pool right like i taught
myself how to swim on an aau trip just
cause i was scared i was scared you get
in the pool
um
everybody be playing around and you know
especially in in black households if
somebody even thought about pushing you
in the pool it was gonna start a fight
it was gonna start a fight so when you
were in high school and
stuff
were your meats like not even close like
when did you start knowing like okay i'm
i'm nice
i was breaking national age group
records from the age of eight on
like i like i mean i probably broke 200
national age group records so national
age group records are the fastest time
swim in that age group so i was 15 16
breaking the open records
so as a 16 year old or a 15 year old i
made my first olympic team
um yeah that's different that's that's
very different and so let's talk for a
second about that type of spotlight like
what
was that like
i was a deer in headlights at my first
olympics a 15 year old kid never
traveled outside of the country i'm here
standing in the olympic final all i
wanted to do was get one second faster
than i did at trials i got 90 98 100 96
100 faster and
i was less than three tenths out of a
second from a medal and i wanted to
medal
and that motivation from from not
meddling catapulted me into 2004.
i say i fall short in 2004 because i
wasn't perfect right i lost
right i don't like to lose we don't like
to lose so yeah exactly so i used that
motivation to then catapult me into 2008
to where
we had all the tools that we needed at
that point to be able to compete at that
level at every single race
during that week in
in beijing i think i swim 60 000 meters
so during a regular training week i was
swimming 80 to 100 000 meters
so because of all the warm-ups warm
downs this that and the other i had to
be extremely prepared and that week took
eight years to get prepared for i had to
swim that that event program over and
over and over again so in oh wait i
didn't see anything else on i was like
almost like a uh racehorse with blinders
on right it was just i knew exactly what
i had to do i knew like
two the second i knew where i had to be
at every every single time what was the
crazy thing uh everybody used to talk
about how many calories is something you
used to have to eat what was it so i was
eating eight to ten thousand calories
every day because when we're swimming i
can fluctuate between 5 and 10 pounds in
a week and when we're trying to be at
our best we want to be at race weight at
all times so i'm forcing myself to eat i
don't like to eat now
i like i can't stand to eat i eat what i
need to
to
when you say give my body what it needs
eight to ten thousand calories a day
what's what's that look like
whatever
literally whatever because you can't eat
all good foods and get that many
calories right so i'm mixing
a pint of ice cream or milkshakes or
cookies or like i mean a breakfast would
have been
you know two breakfast sandwiches a bowl
of grits
omelette short stack of chocolate chip
pancakes and then i'd go take a nap
and then i'd wake up
have i don't know a bagel and a power
bar or a bagel and some fruit if i do
that i'm blowing two hours if i do that
i'm gonna blow up i'm gonna blow up that
is out i cannot do that i mean i had to
maintain that weight so i mean but and
the crazy thing now like i think back to
it i think the reason why i don't like
to eat is because there were always
people over my shoulder being like
you're not eating enough like you got to
put food into your system you know 30
minutes after a workout right like your
entire machine yes like that's what
that's what it felt like so for me i'm
like no i just i want to eat when i want
to eat what i want to eat and
if i say this name to you bob bowman
right that's a coach that you're still
close with
and what i've done over the years
whether it be football or basketball
i've had a ton of different coaches what
is it like to have that relationship
with someone for a long time he's a dad
like
i didn't i didn't always have a dad
growing up so for me
having somebody there that was
one believed in you had confidence in
you but also helped you along the way
um i learned a lot from him and i still
learn a lot from him he's somebody that
comes to the house almost every day he's
grandpa of the boys still still yeah
still so he's coaching here at asu and
yeah he's he's in the pool with the boys
when when the weather's nice and
he's just grandpa there were many times
where you contemplated
like retiring
why didn't you you ain't got not not
just because me and frank told you not
to but
but but why why didn't you the fuel that
was inside of me i mean
for me like in 2012 when i retired
it was it was it was more of a break
than anything else right you know
because for so long my head was staring
at a black line
and i i couldn't do anything else i was
i was never a kid and so i wanted to
find out what being a kid was like so i
think at that point for me to have that
kind of
growing up process and seeing a little
bit on my own learning a little bit on
my own like i just couldn't walk away i
didn't want to walk away
but
the time was right for me to walk away
when i did and
that didn't answer your question at all
but no it did it did i'm i'm over here
just thinking about
how the fact that i got i got two
olympic gold medals and i thought i'd
done i'd done something right
you you sitting over there with 23 gold
medals like which one is sort of like
the the most important is the one where
you won by point yeah i mean
i honestly from a textbook
like
best
performance i would say is probably the
200 free from beijing
yeah and i think that my my favorite
besides that has to be the four feet to
win the same event over four straight
olympics
like that's kind of crazy to think about
um i think i could see it in your face
too like
in 16 right because
you're sort of the old guy
you know what i mean i was the dad of
the team right right basically and i
know you and how competitive you are and
so probably one of the best feelings is
doing what everybody thinks that you
can't
right
how was that like
i mean i have
my whole career was filled with people
who doubted me
um
you know going in 2008 thorpe said i had
never won eight gold medals but
thank you ian
and he knows he knows that was uh i
think he said afterwards he goes i know
how you work and i know how to motivate
you
to go from that spotlight year in and
year out
to
retirement like what was that like
um
it's weird
going from
basically every single day is scheduled
perfect like you don't have to think
right you get up you go to practice you
do this you eat you do this you fall
asleep you go back to practice you
ice tub massage i still can't go back to
sleep like all this stuff
i mean i did it all for 20 years
straight
so like
you take that away
i feel like a kid i don't know what i'm
doing
so for me like
having three kids now i've learned as
they've learned
because my childhood was swimming
that was it
so i'm learning through this process of
trying to
fulfill my day with things that make me
me and make me the best me
you showed a lot of courage to speak
about mental health and talk about the
things that you've dealt with in life
what what finally gave you that courage
and wanted you to
talk about it and share it because we
all deal with it i think it's just a lot
of times
you know people don't talk about it it's
crazy i go back and and
it was 2014
sports illustrated cover story with tim
laden and
we're having an interview here in
phoenix and
whatever whatever question he asked me
just opened me up
dropped my shoulders and i just let it
all out um
i was just ready to you know i think for
me when i checked myself into to get
treatment and to get help
i knew that
that's what i needed and and i was at
the end of the road and i had to get
help i was at a scary place in time
and for a long time i didn't know how to
ask for help
i think once i asked help for the first
time everything became easy so
that question when he asked me whatever
it was
it just opened me up and i felt
comfortable to share everything that i'd
been through um because it was almost
like i
i said to myself i don't care what
people think
this is me yeah and this is my journey
and it makes me who i am so you know the
only way for me to learn and grow and
and
to get over certain things that i've
gone through is to communicate and to
talk about it and and look i'm not
perfect
right like nobody's perfect and and i
struggled a lot through my life my first
impression swell was in 2004
and i went up and down roller coasters
all throughout life like we all do and i
think the coolest part about it is
not that you do it for that reason at
all because you're doing it for yourself
but you just
speaking about it it just gave so many
other people a lot more courage not just
athletes just people in general why do
you think so many people are having a
hard time admitting to grappling with
like these mental issues and
i think it's vulnerability i think
vulnerability is a scary word for a lot
of people yeah and it's a scary word for
me
i remember when i checked into a
treatment center i was shaking
when i went in there because i didn't
know what i'm getting myself into but
i wanted help i didn't like feeling the
way that i did so what else is out there
start asking questions and and look you
know for me as a male athlete i thought
like i i couldn't talk about it right
like you almost you're giving away
weekly weaknesses right like you're
giving away something to your
competitors and and you know that's hard
to do when you're in this field of
battle so you know my approach now is if
we're physically strong and mentally
strong
oh wow
you put those things together yeah we're
in stoppage unstoppable
so you you now live here in phoenix this
beautiful weather
uh your amazing wife nicole you have
three beautiful kids all boys you once
said that she's seen the good the bad
and the ugly
what do you mean by that
yeah you know i mean she's seen
me as
you know
an olympic champion
um
me as a dad me
depressed
me feeling like the worst person on the
planet like she's seen all of it she's
seen every single side of me um and look
i can sit here and talk about it because
it's who i am and i i love who i am it's
taken a long time for me to look in the
mirror and like who i am so for me like
i'll say the hardest thing was going
through the pandemic
being able to understand and manage my
emotions through the pandemic was
overwhelming right like some of the
scariest moments of my life um and
without my wife there
i don't know if i'd be here today
yeah the covet pandemic has been called
a mental health crisis obviously i went
to the bubble uh people are still
dealing with it especially kids
especially children right like kids
being homeschooled doing everything on a
computer and zoom what's something that
you think can can help these kids that
are facing these
these different challenges
loneliness has struck us more than
anything in my opinion over the last two
years and loneliness leads to depression
which leads to other things so for me is
trying to do whatever you can
to have normalcy in your life like what
does that look like you know like i have
no idea like for me like
you know what you do right like for me
like i i have three kids two of them are
at school i mean i play golf i
sit at home i work from home i don't
travel anymore like you know i live here
my family's in la so i get it i get it
but it's like i think trying to find a
routine some kind of routine i think is
always important and and as athletes
it's something that we know we we do
every single day of our life but finding
some kind of normal routine because then
you get to feel like you because the
moment you start feeling not yourself
you start spiraling right so i think
finding ways to be your authentic self
is something that's so important so
self-care right i work out every day six
seven days a week that's something i
have to do for me i go and hit golf
balls once or twice a week i put
headsets in and i just hit golf balls
like i'm in my own world and sometimes i
go swim but i need that
in order to be the best dad that i can
to be the best husband that i can
so
you know we want to give ourselves a
chance so how can we give ourselves a
chance yep let's uh let's hit this range
and see what the see what that swing
looking like these days i like it yep
you know something i always want to ask
you which is
i mean you used to it but it seemed like
it would be kind of weird to me right so
in some of your meets or races
you have teammates
right you have teammates but then you
may do a meet
where the person who was just your
teammate mm-hmm
you're going against him yeah
i mean we know we're here no not really
because
you know most of the time like
internationally we're wearing stars and
stripes right so there's only two of us
so the chance of us going head to head
is pretty likely yeah
it's weird but no i mean i think we can
we can kind of put it past us and we
know when we step up on the block it's
it's business it's competition like
it's not like we don't like you we just
want to beat the hell out of you
what about the kids though how are they
with the water they love it um they all
absolutely love it boomers boomer swims
butterfly and freestyle beckett goes
underwater and he's like our little
dolphin one with five now right yeah i
can't wait
till he
i'm trying to think like
when will boomer
realize
like
who you are you know what i mean like
i'm sure he knows
about the water or whatnot but he
doesn't really know yet right he calls
me aquaman like they all call me awful
man
um
but no i don't i don't think he fully
gets it yet he uh
he he'll always say he's like can you
beat that person can you beat that
person you're like back in the day yes
not anymore though
[Music]
damn this look nice
feels so much better with some oh my
gosh it feels so good
[Music]
[Music]
good roll
dang you must live here or something
a question that i always wonder is if
you didn't swim what would you do
if i could choose anything i would want
to be a golfer just because i i'm
obsessed with the game we do that all
the time
but in reality if i had to choose a
sport that i was good at
um i was a decent decent baseball player
growing up i played catcher i was always
throwing the mask off so i was breaking
the mask all the time baseball players
get paid they do
uh a salary cat or a lacrosse player
that's that's the only thing i grew up
on the east coast so i played lacrosse
oh man um so yeah i was a long stick
midi
and um
and then when i was 11 my coach just
basically said no more and
focused on swimming
so
um
what's next
besides me hopefully making this putt
i mean my biggest thing now is
all really around mental health
um
i want to i want to try and lower the
suicide numbers as much as i can there
are too many people that are taking
their own lives and i want to help the
people that are out there suffering
when you get a chance to hear somebody
say that you changed and impact their
lives that's
that's
probably even more gratifying than a
gold medal now it's the best feeling in
the world
um for me being able to to have
people share their experiences their
moments what they've been through
showing their vulnerability oh my gosh
dude
it you can't put it into words it's the
greatest feeling um i the one thing i
can say is i encourage every single
person out there
to communicate to open up to talk
don't stuff things down don't
compartmentalize because that stuff just
piles up piles up on top of each other
and before you know it it all just
explodes
i say that from firsthand because i know
i was really good at compartmentalizing
throughout my career
and i can't do that anymore
that's real
well
come on man appreciate you for sure for
real always
definitely thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you